[Musique]
entretiens politiques avec luc chatel
maire de bougival bonjour alors vous
êtes maire depuis 2013 vous aviez vous
été premier adjoint vous avez succédé à
jean pascal qui avait démissionné puis
j'avais été élus en 2014 réélu il ya un
an au mois de mars
vous êtes présentés vous y tenez
beaucoup je crois comme maire sans
étiquette
est ce que ça veut dire que pour vous le
la fonction de maire c'est une fonction
politique un peu particulière
bah oui vous avez quand même quand on
est adjoint on est toujours en arrière
de la tête attendait mais on est devant
la fonction de maire c'est une fonction
de localisation local c'est une fonction
de proximité option avec des rapports
humains qui sont essentiels c'est une
fonction très variés et techniques très
concrète en ligne avec le quotidien des
habitants
et puis il faut avoir une vision pour
une vision et il pouvoir mettre en
oeuvre cette cette vision à travers des
projets et mettre toute son énergie pour
que ce projet puisse voir de vous
envoyer fait vraiment une fonction
prépare la coke goût d'être vous avez
annoncé votre candidature de pour être
renouvelée commun comme maire de
bougival
vous avez dit mais j'ai hésité quand
même avant de me représenter
qu'est ce qui vous a hésité c'était
votre premier mandat plein comme maire
est ce qu'il ya des choses qui nous ont
surprises pendant pendant ce mandat
dirait que j'ai peut-être paraître un
peu hors du temps
mais pour moi exercer cette fonction
c'est d'abord un grand honneur et c'est
une chance extraordinaire que je ressens
toujours au plus profond de moi même
chaque jour depuis que je suis élu maire
est la contrepartie de ça c'est au
niveau de l'exigence d'exigences
éthiques et morales qu'il faut s'imposer
dans toute son action dans ses décisions
et puis donc il faut savoir accepter de
ne pas avoir raison c'est pas un
problème pour moi mais aussi de ne pas
pouvoir satisfaire tout le monde mais ça
c'est dit souvent beaucoup plus
compliqué parce que au nom d'une
conviction personnelle parce que ce qui
est demandé n'est pas juste au nom de
l'intérêt général ou tout simplement
parce que vous n'avez pas le pouvoir
légal de le faire on sait engendre une
en permanence une très forte pression et
même parfois violentes
1 / sur la fonction donc oui pour être
mais il faut avoir une très forte
motivation et cette motivation
permettent d'avoir d'aller puiser la
force nécessaire pourquoi avancer le
fort possible et ils ont que oui non non
je voulais simplement dire que le fait
de se représenter c'est d'abord se poser
la question bat suivre les vite y en ait
envie des jeux
on a beau pouvoir apporter encore ta
créativité de la valeur ajoutée et ses
guitares et bien sûr sinon tu
représentes conduit positif
oui et vous avez évidemment ajouté que
c'était une fonction qui existent ou
faut 1 1
un plein temps enfin c'est ce qu'on peut
faire que ça quand on est maire que
comme vous alors parlons un peu de
bougival c'est une ville qui suit à peu
près une vingtaine de guides de
kilomètres de paris qui est loin de
versailles de saint germain c'est la
ville dans laquelle devront séjourner
beaucoup d'impressionnistes c'est une
ville aussi littéraire il ya eu la
maison de tourgueniev qui était le
disque le plus français des écrivains
russes est d'ailleurs on publie je le
signale une correspondance de torts et
nief avec flaubert c'est joe sakic est
absolument admirable plus plus proche de
nous c'est la ville de new l'habite
neymar osi
donc quand on quand on voit d'où ça
qu'on se l'imaginé l'ailé les la scène
qui coule on se dit voilà c'est quand
même la ville de la qualité de la vie
oui bien sûr de la qualité de la vie et
c'est une ville qui ça qui a tiré très
vite une population qui s'est développé
au cours des années des années 60 70
qui à part sa proximité à la fois avec
la vallée de l'automobile qui a fait la
richesse des yvelines et sa continuité
de la défense et de paris qui a attiré
des urbains parisiens qui avaient besoin
de ce d'aller dans un cadre d'air dans
une note amère
les trois précédents et puis c'est aussi
une ville qui qui attirait beaucoup de
familles
oui c'est on a eu deux enfants
scolarisés à l'époque c'est avec 20
points 8500 habitants on parle de
personnel à bougival à tous les records
et on en est ressort de redescendre un
peu en dessous de 700 messi se fournir
c'est que depuis la crise à cauville ont
bac de bougival d' accueil encore plus
de jeunes je ne jure pas surtout vous
des familles attirées par '
dans cet environnement exceptionnel
situé et je pense aussi par la
trajectoire développement durable nous
avons lancé il ya presque quinze ans
maintenant et qui fait de notre ville
une des plus dynamiques dans ce dans ce
domaine et je crois que ça apporte
énormément à à nos familles à force
apporter notamment aux habitants et
c'est ça qui fait jaillir que bougival a
été classée comme la première ville
concernant la qualité de la vie des
yvelines donc félicitations si on peut
dire justement quand il ya un quart
tient et vous en parliez du
développement durable notamment la
responsabilité d'un maire quand on a
comme ça une ville qui se passe est
formidable il faut à la fois conserver
le passé mais faut il faut bouger aussi
ah oui très clairement il faut il faut
bouger et justement parlé de trajectoire
avec le développement durable c'est un
horizon à long terme avec des actions
qui ce qu'il faut mettre en oeuvre au
fur et à mesure de ses moyens
donc on peut avoir et des moyens et pas
seulement financier mais aussi des
moyens techniques
nous avons par exemple en 2012 on refait
complètement notre notre éclairage
public
cette année on va mettre en place une
hydrolienne qui va produire de
l'électricité voyez aucune revue en
avance sur sûr c'est surtout ce point
et plus il faut s'opposer absolument une
densification sauvage plus respectueuse
et environnement ça c'est très important
pour que l'on puisse garder notre y
croire et garder notre âme et que les
bougies vallée soit fier d'habiter
alors il y avait il ya une autre
spécificité qui est celle de votre
gouvernance on nous avait parlé ici dans
une autre émission sais que vous avez
beaucoup favorisé les procédures de
démocratie participative dans votre
ville
pourquoi l'avoir fait et comment ça se
passait ce que les habite aussi sont
habitués et sont demandeurs aujourd'hui
c'est pour moi une ville c'est comme
anormales vivant et pour pouvoir évoluer
dans la bonne direction
elle a besoin de se nourrir en
permanence d'information de commentaires
de nouvelles idées autrefois pas entre
deux élections à tous les six ans tiens
c'est pas grand chose
communiquez pas vraiment la population
finalement c'est un peu faire mourir la
démocratie et donc pour que la
nourriture soit bonne
reprendre l'image il faut pouvoir
toucher sorte de personne il qu'on ne
peut n'arrivait pas à faire des réunions
et donc le d'habitude ces personnes on
va à travers cet outil qu'on a mis en
place qui s'appelle auteurs qui nous
permet de faire passer l'information
interroger les personnes de façon
interactive au monde descend donc on va
justement duchesne toutes sortes de
populations et de finalement rentrer
dans une construction d'une construction
bien sûr c'est toujours le conseil
municipal qui qui décide d'avancer
hummer mais ça permet d'avoir des
informations précieuses sur ce que mes
bougies vallée pense de tel ou tel
projet sur ce paysage be et puis
finalement à t-elle
l'entreprise avait l'outil pour moi ça
fait ressortir dans notre processus là
on pourrait éviter vu qu évidemment la
crise sanitaire qui a un peu changé le
mandat des maires mais il y a une
actualité dramatique qui a eu lieu dans
les yvelines qui ont été une fois encore
touché par le par le terrorisme c'est
d'assassinât de cette policière à
rambouillet qu'elle est quelle est votre
réaction face à cette ce nouvel attentat
les ce nouvel acte de terrorisme
c'est évidemment c'est évidemment
dramatique il n'y a pas de mots pour
pourquoi qualifier cet acte
en même temps ce dont on se rend compte
c'est que notre société est extrêmement
fragile face à des situations quelqu'un
d'un peu déséquilibré fait ce qu'un peu
cependant rien et bien vérité
déséquilibré va enfin pouvoir
entreprendre comme action et 7 de
l'abstrait cité n'arrive finalement
pouvoir si reconstruire ce type de
situation parce que elle est le fait de
personnes qui désirent dans le froid
très isolée maniement de la ji
et je pense que c'est lié à cette
fragilité que citer la crise sanitaire
c'est le déséquilibre fils dans notre
société qui se sont renforcés et que je
pense que ça devrait être un des sujets
qui doit être au coeur du grand débat
démocratique qui s'annonce avec les
élections elle il en fait c'est comment
on trouve évidemment l'équilibré de
notre société
comment construire une société qu'ils
soient créatifs qui sont entreprenants
qui soit durable est il qu'ils leur
donnent à chacun d'eux de l'espoir oui
qui donne à chaque envie d'avancer dans
cette société
quand on laisse les gens comme ça sans
pouvoir en donner le l'envi d'être de
faire partie de cette société
malheureusement ces équipes se l
événement tragique entre amati que l'on
connaît peu connu merci beaucoup
l'aigle a t-elle et voilà il se rappelle
quand même voilà bougival première ville
des yvelines pour la qualité de la vie
c'est pas rire merci merci beaucoup
merci
[Musique]